-We're about to play
a game of "Catchphrase."
Tariq and I are a team,
and we'll be facing off
against some
very worthy opponents.
He is the host of
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Give it up for Seth Meyers!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. This is it.
This is it. This is it.
-This is it, buddy.
Looking good.
-Right here?
-I think you're here.
-Right. Perfect.
Hello, everybody!
Hello! Thank you!
-And you can see Seth's partner
in the FX series
"Impeachment:
American Crime Story."
Please welcome Cobie Smulders!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome. Tariq. Cobie.
Tariq, you go there.
Cobie, you go here.
-I'm here?
-Yeah, you guys are -- Yeah.
All right, now, here's --
All right, now,
here's how the game works.
Seth, you're gonna start
the round by pressing start
on this buzzer
and then drawing a clue
from the top of this pile.
-Mm-hmm.
-You have to get your partner
to guess the clue
as quickly as possible
then hand the buzzer off
to the person on your right,
which would be me.
You can make
any physical gesture,
you can say whatever you want,
except you can't say any word
in the actual clue.
If you're holding the buzzer
when it goes off,
your team loses that round.
And we play three rounds.
Seth, when you're ready,
press start.
Let's -- Let's draw your clue.
Come on, Tariq.
-So I hold it in my hand...
-Yep.
-...until she guesses it?
-That's correct.
-All right. Great.
[ Beeping ]
Where Germans drink beer,
annually. It's --
-Oh, oh -- the -- the --
-Named after a month
that Halloween is in.
-Oh, my God!
The -- The --
-What month is Halloween in?
-November -- November --
Oh, Oktoberfest. Oktoberfest.
-"What month is Halloween?"
All right. Here we go.
Uh, James Bond.
When he orders a martini...
-Shaken, not stirred.
-That's correct.
-Okay, it's in Italy,
and it goes this way --
-The Boot.
-And it's giant.
-The Leaning Tower of Pisa.
-Yes.
-Your favorite show. You just
put the whole world onto it.
-"Squid Game."
-Yes.
-It's when you don't text
somebody back. Haunted.
-Oh. Ghosted. Ghosted.
-Uh, uh, Video game.
Kids play it. Blocks. Building.
-[ Buzzer ]
-Tetris. Oh, my God!
-Aah!
-Candy Crush! Ahh!
-Sweating. Full body sweat.
-But it was the time.
-We won the round.
-Uh-huh.
-Just to be clear.
-But let's not forget.
Cobie said,
"What month is Halloween in?"
-Right, right. And then
she said, "Novemberfest!"
-November! November!
-All right. Here we go.
Now we're gonna play
one more round.
This one is worth 10,000 points.
-All right.
-So it's anyone's game,
now that we know the rules.
-Great. Sure, sure, sure.
-Geez Louise.
-Yep, this is the way it works.
All right, good. Cobie,
do you want to start us off?
-Okay, sure.
-Press the button and go for it.
-[ Sighs ] Okay.
-[ Beeping ]
[British accent] We're -- We're
a British singing girl group.
From back in the day.
-Yeah.
-Sporty.
-The Spice Girls.
-Yes.
-Nice. You had that.
You had that.
-Okay, this is what you do
if you're in the water.
You're swimming,
but you're not moving.
Oh, yeah, you're swimming,
but you're not --
-Yeah, yeah.
-With your arms.
-Yeah.
-Doggy paddle.
-Yes. Yes.
-Oh, gosh.
Um -- this is when -- Wow.
-No.
-Oh!
-Oktoberfest!
-Okay, this is --
When you yell, you are --
-Screaming.
-Like, somebody
who has a lot of --
I mean -- There's just no way --
-Help, help.
-Would you be able to get that?
-No.
[ Buzzer ]
-I am so sorry.
-Whoa, whoa.
-I'm sorry.
-No. I don't know. I think --
-I mean, it was --
it was "clout."
I mean, I'm sorry.
-The guesses
got extremely harder.
-Yeah.
-I know.
-It jumped from "Minecraft"
to "clout."
-Clout!
-I think we go one more round.
-Yeah, I think we're tied.
We're tied.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-At this point, we're tied.
-Okay.
-Clout.
-Yeah, clout.
-♪ You got something,
you've got -- ♪
I don't know.
-I couldn't -- Yeah.
I apologize.
-No. No.
-I feel like that
landed on me after I...
-I apologize.
-...gave you shade
for "Oktoberfest."
-No, I apologize on all of us.
-It's okay. It's okay.
-We're -- It's a tie. Like,
this is the one that matters.
-Okay.
-Thank you.
-Okay. Let's do it. You ready?
-I appreciate...
-Yeah. You brought us back.
-Cool.
-...your clout.
-You brought us back.
-The voice of reason. Yes.
Clout man.
-Got some clout.
-Let's go. Okay.
Clear out the --
You know, these things.
-Cobwebs.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-When you go to bed...
-"I'm gonna go..."
-Sleep.
-In baseball, you get a...
-Home run.
-But when it's only one base,
it's a...
-First base.
-I use my boxers...
-Gloves.
-I'm gonna go to bed.
I'm gonna...
Knockout. Knockout.
-Something the bag.
-I'm gonna punch the --
punch the bag.
What's another word for "bag"?
-Hit the bag. Hit the bag.
Hitting the bag.
-Hit the...
-When I'm going to sleep...
-Hitting the hay!
-No!
-No?!
-Hacky...
-Hittin' the sack!
Waaaaah!
-Get out of here.
-The winners! The winners!
Cobie Smulders and Seth Meyers!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-You had a heart attack.
Oh, my God.
-Oh.
-"Hit the hay."
-Oh, my God.
-"Hit the hay" is real.
-That is how you play the game
right there.
That is Seth Meyers,
Cobie Smulders, Tariq Trotter.